MIKHAIL NAGANOV: Hi, my name
is Mikhail Naganov.
I'm a software engineer
at Google working
on Chrome for Android.
In this video, I will talk about
building modern mobile
websites using Chrome
for Android and
Chrome Developer Tools.
Not surprisingly, a mobile web
site runs in a browser, just
as a regular website.
But it's more than just a
simplified version of the
desktop web site.
A modern mobile website takes
advantage from the fact that
it runs on a mobile device
and integrates itself
tightly with it.
Chrome for Android and other
mobile browsers offer APIs
that allow web sites to
implement first class touch
support, tactile feedback, and
provide access to the current
device state, such as
orientation and geolocation.
This makes it possible to create
websites that are very
close by their look and feel to
native mobile applications.
The question is, what are the
advantages of implementing
your application as a mobile
website versus implementing it
as a native application
for mobile platforms?
First of all, you have to deal
with a single platform, HTML5,
which is implemented
uniformly across
different mobile platforms.
This is a great saving of effort
if you compare it with
the need of porting your native
mobile application
across different implementation
stacks of
various mobile platforms.
Also, languages used in the
HTML5 platform, JavaScript,
HTML and CSS, are high level
languages that make
programming a lot easier
to compared to native
applications programming.
Browsers are hot at the moment,
and they are all
evolving very fast.
New features are added literally
every month.
Having ported Chrome to the
Android platform, we intend to
follow Chrome's release program
and provide beta and
developer channels for you to
preview the new features.
It's also simpler for users to
get access to websites, as
they require no installation
procedures.
And updates to new versions
are invisible because they
don't need modifications
on the client.
From a security standpoint, web
sites provide a different
model than native
applications.
They run in a browser sandbox.
The user is being asked by
the browser to confirm a
permission for an action,
for example, to
access user's location.
As soon as the action takes
place, instead of providing a
long list of permissions
during applications
installation, that's now what
it usually takes care of.
There are several points that
you need to keep in mind while
planning the development
of your mobile website.
I will name the most
important of them.
First of all, there are
a lot of different
devices in the wild.
We have cheap phones with small
screens on one side of
the spectrum and high-end
phones with high density
screens and tablets on the
other, and everything you can
imagine in between.
Not mentioning that every device
can be used in the
portrait or a landscape
orientation.
Obviously, your site needs to
be ready for that, and might
need to provide different
layouts for
different types of screens.
And then touch input requires a
different strategy comparing
to traditional keyboard
and mouse input.
On one side it's more intuitive,
but on the other
it's less precise than using the
mouse input, and typing on
an on-screen keyboard is much
slower than a physical one.
Mobile devices have less
computing power than regular
computers, and the power
consumption question
is vital for them.
There should be no waste of
precious CPU cycles in your
application.
Network connectivity might vary
depending on where your
user is situated.
Your website must be prepared
to work without any network
connection.
Happily, most modern browsers
support offline storage and
can inform your website
about the current
state of the network.
There is a problem that a lot of
mobile users are stuck with
outdated mobile platform
releases, running old versions
of browsers.
But as I have mentioned earlier,
we intend to shake
this situation up by updating
Chrome for Android as often as
the desktop version.
By the way, it's a good idea
to get the most from your
desktop Chrome browser debugging
features while
developing a web site
for mobile.
Developing on a desktop is more
convenient and involves
less set up steps.
What mobile features can be
tested using Chrome Developer
Tools and third party tools
on your desktop?
Surprisingly, a lot.
In the recent versions of Google
Chrome, you have an
ability to override user agent
strings with the ones used in
mobile platforms.
And what's even more important,
Chrome Developer
Tools can automatically adjust
your window size to the size
of the device screen.
Also, it's possible to emulate
touch events with your mouse.
Multi-touch event simulation
is also feasible, although
setting it up is more involved,
and perhaps it will
be just easier for you
to test it on a
physical mobile device.
It's awesome that you can
develop and test the lion's
share of your mobile website
functionality without even
running an emulator.
It would be ideal if you could
do everything on desktop, but
unfortunately some of mobile
environment specific features
should be tested on
real devices.
Of course, you can't provide
the same interaction
experience from desktop, just
because your desktop or laptop
computers feel differently
from mobile devices.
For your website to provide
intuitive interaction, it must
work with a real device and
strive to make the interaction
as natural as possible.
Obviously, hardware platforms
of mobile devices are
significantly different
from desktop boxes.
And actions that are performed
with ease by powerful desktop
processors may significantly
slow down
their mobile siblings.
Not mentioning the GPU
acceleration pipeline is
different on mobile devices.
As with regular web site
development, you need to test
your site on real browsers,
because even despite the fact
that many of them are based on
the same rendering engine,
differences in versions
and vendor patches may
significantly affect the
behavior of the website.
And the last important point is
network connectivity, that
I have mentioned before.
Although it's possible to try
to simulate different
networking conditions on your
desktop by inserting
artificial delays into network
packets processing, or drop in
packets, the setup of such tools
is usually complicated.
While on a real device, you
can easily switch between
wi-fi, 3G, and 2G network
connections to model network
conditions that end
users may have.
And now let's proceed
to the most exciting
part of this video.
Demos.
I will be using the laptop
computer and a tablet running
Android Ice Cream Sandwich with
Google Chrome for Android.
Here we have a simple web page
that draws a rotating Chrome
logo using HTML5
canvas element.
And you can interact with this
Chrome logo by touching it.
You can slow down its rotation
by putting your
finger on it like this.
You can also resize it by
holding it with one finger and
dragging the second
one like this.
Let's see what can be tested
on your desktop by using
mobile features emulation,
available in the latest
version of Chrome
Developer Tools.
If you're a web developer, we
strongly encourage you using
Chrome Developer channel
releases, or Chrome Canary
releases to get access to
the latest features
that we have in Chrome.
Now I'm running my page on the
desktop version of Chrome.
Let's open Chrome
Developer Tools,
then open their settings.
And here you can see the user
agent group of settings.
By using it, we can emulate
screen sizes of mobile devices
and emulate touch events
using the mouse.
After I set my user agent
setting to Nexus S and have
device metrics override enabled,
you can see the tab
running the application will
have the same pixel dimensions
as the screen of a Nexus S4.
And they can switch between
portrait and landscape
orientations by pressing
this button.
Touch events emulation is also
pretty straightforward.
You just need to check the
corresponding check
box, and that's it.
Pressing the left mouse button
will generate touchstart,
touchmove, and touchend
events.
Setting up for remote web
debugging is really easy.
First you need to make your
website accessible to your
mobile device.
To achieve this, I will connect
my laptop and my
tablet to the same
Wi-Fi router.
And I have a website running
on my laptop.
And in order to connect
it, I need to know
my laptop's IP address.
Now I'm entering the address in
Chrome on the tablet, and
here is my application.
For setting up remote web
debugging, we need to perform
several steps.
These steps are documented on
the Google Developers site.
First, you need to connect
your device to your host
machine using a USB wire.
Then, you need to enable USB
debugging in the device
settings and enable USB web
debugging in Chrome.
Chrome for Android will open a
port for remote debugging, and
you will need to forward this
port to your host machine in
order to be able
to connect it.
You will need to have Android
SDK platform tools installed
on your host machine.
And after that, you will be able
to navigate to the remote
debugging landing
page from your
Chrome browser on desktop.
So I'm connecting my tablet
to the laptop by USB.
Now I'm going to the
DY settings and
enabling remote debugging.
It's also recommended to enable
the stay awake setting
so your screen will
not go to sleep.
Now in Chrome, I'm going to
the Settings panel and
enabling remote debugging
there.
After that, your mobile
device is all set up.
On my laptop, I'm issuing a port
forwarding command, and
my local port, 9222, is being
forwarded to the remote web
debugging port opened by
Chrome on the tablet.
So when I'm navigating to local
host 9222 on my laptop,
I'm getting straight to the
remote debugging landing page,
and can start debugging.
So let's check how
our application
works on the tablet.
To our surprise, the touch
handling code that was working
pretty well on the desktop
doesn't behave as it should on
the tablet.
Let's investigate that.
In the Developer Tools I'm going
to the Event Listener
Breakpoints sidebar and setting
a breakpoint on the
touchmove event.
Now when I touch the
application, the debugger
breaks into my application
execution at the entry point
of the event handler.
Now I'm using Developer Tools'
live editing feature to insert
some logging into my
event handlers.
As I press Command+S, the code
is being sent to the device.
Now I'm switching to the console
tab, and here I can
watch in real time how my event
handlers are being invoked.
You can see as I'm touching
the screen, I see console
messages appear in
the console.
Now we can see the problem.
Our application only receives
a touchstart event, a couple
of touch moves, and
no touchend.
I'm running a developer version
of Chrome for Android,
and it seems to have a problem
with following touch events.
This doesn't happen in the
desktop version of Chrome.
That's why on the desktop, our
application was working fine.
Actually, what you anyway need
to do in the touchmove handler
is to call event.preventDefault
in order
to prevent the browser
from attempting
to scroll your content.
This prevents the touchmove
event from being processed by
the browser, and it just
passes the event to our
application.
So now after sending this
change to the tablet by
pressing Command+S, the
application should start
working properly.
Yes, it works, and we have
finally tested the behavior in
multi-touch.
It also works great.
Now let's try to take a CPU
profile of the same
application running on a desktop
machine and on tablet,
and see if we can spot
any differences.
As drawing a Chrome logo isn't
a very CPU intensive task,
I'll add a code that displays
ten thousands of points on the
screen, setting their color
depending on whether they get
into the Chrome logo or not.
I'm selecting the line of code
and invoking Evaluate in
Console command on it.
As you can see, the frame rate
has dropped significantly.
Now I'm doing the same
thing on the tablet.
Here the frame rate drop is even
more visible, as the CPU
is slower than on the laptop.
Now let's take CPU profiles on
both devices and compare them.
First I'll make the size of
the window on the desktop
browser the same as on my
tablet, 1280 by 800, with the
help of Developer Tools.
Then I'll make radiuses of
Chrome logos to match.
I will look at the size in the
console for the mobile side
and copy the value to
the desktop side.
Now I'm starting CPU profiling
for the site running in the
desktop browser.
OK, we're done.
Now I'm doing the same for the
mobile browser remotely.
Done.
Let's compare the profiles
side by side.
What you can see is that time
shares for the same functions
are significantly different
between
desktop and mobile versions.
The function named program
is the native code
of the browser itself.
This may happen due to
several reasons.
Different CPUs, different
versions of the V8 Javascript
engine used, and differences
in X86 versus code
generation in V8.
This experiment confirms my
statement that running and
debugging your site on a real
device provides a great
insight and reveals new aspects
of the site behavior
that can't be seen while
debugging on desktop.
Thanks to Chrome for Android
USB debugging feature, the
experience that you have is
as good as for the desktop
version of Chrome.
Thank you very much for
watching this video.
For your convenience, here
I'm providing some
useful links for you.
First of all, we have a page on
the Google Developer site
that contains the setup
instructions
for remote web debugging.
If you want to know more about
using Chrome Developer Tools,
there is a section on Google
Developers site for you.
If you happen to be on Google
I/O, I would highly recommend
attending the Chrome Developer
Tools session for a deep dive
into advanced development
techniques.
That's it.
Thank you and goodbye.